So I started ballet when I was 10.
Dance basically saved me.
It's a very constant thing in my life.
Did not come from a fortunate background,
single parent.
You know,
we had bouts of homelessness
in our lives and ballet for me,
made me feel like I could
overcome anything in my life.
I'm too, yeah, I'm a professional
ballerina and actress.
My name is Kay flow and
I like to freestyle.
I didn't really take any studio classes
or do any of the normal things for dance.
I've made my own path.
And then two years ago I made it happen
and I moved to La from Missouri and then
I got into a motorcycle accident last
year around this time and I couldn't walk
and I almost had to give up
my dance. So dancing, uh,
since I've been through so much with it,
it means more than anything and I'm never
giving up no matter if my legs get cut
off.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, hello. Hey, are you a dancer? Yeah.
That's awesome. It's nice to meet you.
My name is Kaitlin Kaisa and sue. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like what's
it to? Yeah. It's like, ah. Yeah.
You Do Probably Ballet, Huh? Yes, they
do. What did he do? I street dance.
Oh Wow. Actually had a friend who
taught me a little bit about Lais. Oh,
I can do a little bit,
look at you live your life.
My first impression was he seemed
pretty cool. I was like, okay,
brought in like a motorcycle helmet
and he had his glasses on. I was like,
are you a dancer? Like are you a
painter? Are you a rapper? I didn't know.
All right.
You want me to like stretch
and warm up? Yeah, I see.
I stretch pretty good. Just the way
she was standing, holding herself.
I could tell this is what she
does and she's very passionate.
Just by her standing there who I
already knew that we were going to make
something beautiful.
Maybe one of us can be on the ground
and one of us can be hovering above the
other person or something like that.
Like let's say I would rather be up.
Okay. Let's say, let's see.
Combination of everything.
I'm coming somewhere. I don't know
the person about to collaborate with.
I don't even know what I'm not to do,
so it's always the anxiousness.
I was feeling like,
what is going do you want to go up?
Maybe I'm also extremely shy.
I get really nervous in my head.
I was like a whole,
I'm not awkward because I'm usually
really awkward, so it was like,
I hope this goes really well. I wonder
if I can do a split turn. So I got,
I was just confused whenever I was doing
my freestyle or what the cue was for
the screen counting. Do you count or no?
I usually don't. Oh, okay. Well then,
but you can hear me. He talks a basis
goes right. Yes, let's do it that way.
Probably my biggest Kryptonite has just
stayed on the account with the feeling
of the music.
It's very hard if that helps.
All my big movements are
starting with a base.
What are some of the challenges
that you guys are coming up?
Will China mailed trying to,
trying to nail the ballet with it
with street and there was a couple of
positions where I was like,
oh we can do this.
And then we'd like sit there and
be like, wait, we can't really,
I wonder if I can just do the same.
I don't know what those are called.
The ballet flat.
Whenever you do the
like a two page I'd pay.
Are you going to do it too?
No, I was saying I can do the
street version of WHATSAPP.
It's just like a process to figure out
what the best option is of what we are
both capable of and there's so many
options that that can be overwhelming a
little bit.
But man we,
we fought through it and we came together
and came up with some really cool
concepts to this guy.
Like wave around you. It, yeah.
The challenge is is that we
made it really challenging.
Like I think that like we both got excited
about each other's willingness to try
new things that like once we found like
that open door we pull just like ran
through it. So like, you know, there's
like interesting lifts in turns and,
and cutting.
I don't do like,
it's really cool that like we were able
to take both the things that scared us
and put it together and I'm pretty happy
with what we've been able to create.
Wasn't really easy,
but it almost felt like it
was meant to happen. Okay.
This is already a so cool.
Wow.
Hi.
Wow,
man.
He was a beautiful process.
Like to go into unknown territory and just
hit it and get it done in a few hours.
I love being challenged and this is like
one of the most challenging things I've
done in awhile.
These speaks in the language of like
street dancer and in this instance,
and speak in a language of Ballerina. So
how do we use our different backgrounds?
It speak to each other in a collaborative
manner to meet this like common ground,
which is cool.
I think we've found it.
Okay.